in 2010 Infinity Ward the studio that
created and evolved the call of duty
franchise imploded the firing of two
high-profile employees Vince Zampella
and Jason West sparked an employee drain
of 46 members most of whom formed
respawn entertainment to work on the
titanfall series in the aftermath
meanwhile intent on maintaining its
legacy Infinity Ward continue down its
own path it released call of duty ghosts
in 2013 and although it was
well-received Infinity Ward took a
backseat to sledgehammer games in
treyarch studios that released their own
call of duty titles to glow in critical
response Infinity Ward created call of
duty in 2003 and modernized in 2007 and
despite the talents still present at the
company after ghosts it was a shadow of
its former self it had taken a tertiary
role in a three studio development cycle
in the months following ghosts the
remaining team members were faced with a
difficult question who exactly is
infinity ward two years ago that very
question was posed Dave stole the new
studio head and the leader of infinity
ward's reconstruction it's kind of nice
to bring some new juice into the into
the mix when you know guys like me have
been around since beginning you relate
all right don't let it happen again mark
down your permanent record sometimes you
get stuck in your own way of doing
things and so I think you tell them is
always good
after pulling from numerous Studios
across the world the Infinity Ward of
today is in many ways a new thing
entirely they have members from Naughty
Dog they have people from Crystal
Dynamics they have veterans from dice
Treyarch and sledgehammer games but as a
collective unit the team has yet to
prove itself we call duty infinite
warfare they're trying to do just that
the needs of our planet were greater
than she could supply so we went beyond
the reaches of our atmosphere
the new frontier offered the promise of
a new beginning but the distance gave
way to a movement with no connection to
the place we call home you tell me about
your history with like games in general
what brought you to infinity ward and
why not sure well my history goes way
back to nineteen ninety-five working on
crash bandicoot it was with my dog for a
dozen or so years and then started at
infinity ward in 2014 to work on
infinite warfare soups tips through you
know people maybe know about the fact
that infinity ward merged with neversoft
in 2014 and that was right around the
same time that was just a little bit
after i started here and a few other
guys started here and so we're really
building in a lot of ways a new studio
Infinity Ward is really kind of a studio
made up of leads right everyone here is
super senior they've been in the
industry for a really long time worked
on a lot of titles working a lot of Call
of Duty titles in a lot of cases guys
like Brian Horton Taylor Jacob you guys
who are new to this but come from games
like Last of Us been charted or tomb
raider whatever they bring a different
kind of appreciation for not just the
game itself but how the process of
making the game I love the Infinity Ward
that we have now because it does have a
lot of veterans that came from the
Infinity Ward studio and it's got a lot
of new passionate people that studied
what call of duty was and did a lot of
games prior and then took with that
knowledge and brought into this
franchise and I think it just made it a
better thing before
and so we're trying to take the best of
all of these studios and form a brand
new culture that utilizes the best
methods of one studio the best methods
of another studio the structure of
another studio and try to like combine
all those things into something that's
better and greater than the sum of its
parts and it's been really exciting to
be part of this kind of rebirth of this
place of course Infinity Ward isn't the
only studio with call of duty experience
with the release of call of duty 3 in
2006 developer treyarch entered the mix
allowing for more frequent franchise
releases years later after supporting
Infinity Ward on modern warfare 3
sledgehammer games would create its
first solo title with advanced warfare
the result is a yearly release schedule
filled by a three studio rotation IC
call of duty as being more than just a
franchise I see it as being so big that
I almost consider it like a genre in and
of itself and there's a lot of room
within that genre for sort of different
takes on on it you know where it we're
in an interesting place right now
because there are three studios that are
very talented studios with a bunch of
experienced developers in it but there's
and there's certainly a lot of friendly
competition you know I mean I think all
the three Studios want to keep
progressing the franchise right we we
will always want to remain cognizant of
what makes callofduty call of duty and
where that fun comes from but we also
want to keep extending it we don't want
to just kind of repeat ourselves over
and over again and therein seems to be
the biggest challenge when making a call
of duty game creating something that
fits within the shared call of duty
universe but also sets the title and the
studio that made it apart from the crowd
Treyarch and sledgehammer have done
exactly that with their recent releases
and in creating infinite warfare
Infinity Ward itself could move out
front again
there was definitely a lot of like
discussions going on about like kind of
testing the limits of what call of duty
are like what would it what is it as
Brandon like what could it be we started
into introducing new technology into the
ground combat The Jackal came in and
picked you up but you went and launched
up into space all of the destroyer at
enemies destroy up into space you saw it
jump away you know somewhere different
so you controlled your jackal and landed
on your own carrier Roger zulima coming
into got out of your ship damn good to
see you in Santa race went up to the
bridge you ordered a crew to make the
jump to follow it you saw the jump
happen launched out
you know combat breach inside sabotage
the ship watched explode and got out
just in time and it was all a seamless
but it required that some of us
old-timers you know kind of break
ourself out of the normal way of doing
things which is hardened what I loved
about that is we got to take the best
parts of all the cultures and what each
of those people brought the studio and
use the best of what they did and make
it into this really cool new thing that
I don't think you know I've ever seen
done before is no distress
this kind of melting pot of developers
that is this kind of knew I w is really
gelled now as a team you know it's like
you go through your galvanized a little
bit by the horrors of you know finishing
a game and I think we've come out the
other side is a great studio with a lot
of new talent a lot of new you know i
would call our studio a strong narrative
studio which I wouldn't have said
necessarily you know in the past after
speaking with numerous members of
infinity ward during this video shoot
that's the one thing that kept coming up
that focus on narrative I don't know
about you but to me call duty has always
stood out because of its multiplayer yes
its campaigns have usually delivered
massive set pieces memorable moments and
engaging story lines but the
customizable load outs and massive
player base of the pvp arena have always
been the signifier of each entries
longevity but maybe that's why the
members of infinity ward's seem to be
lending more weight to its single player
campaign this time around she got
feelings Ethan I do lieutenant I do I
carry the bringing of a human former
holy [ __ ] are you serious no ma'am not
maybe the studio that started call of
duty in the first place recognizes that
this time they can push things a little
farther maybe this time around Infinity
Ward could do something entirely new as
creators we want to challenge ourselves
we want to do things that we haven't
done before that's why I think a lot of
us are drawn to the games industry
because really games are really at a
real embryonic stage still in the grand
scheme of things on the next episode of
the series we speak to the members at
infinity ward about infinite Warfare's
narrative focus the decision to bring
the series to space to create an
open-ended campaign and the efforts to
focus on a personal intimate story
rather than complex military tactics as
the studio tells it these elements have
all coalesced to create something that
might put the studio at the head of the
call of duty pack again and if all goes
well with that plan Infinity Ward could
very well resume that call of duty
mantle
you